فوضى عارمه عقب خساره نادي اسبانيول امام
فريق برشلونه في ديربي اقليم كاتالونيا
الحد فريق برشلونه لقبه السابع والعشرين
تاريخيا في الدوري الاسباني جماهير
اسبانيول نزلت الى الملعب بعقبه نهايه
مباراه برشلونه التي انتهت بفوزه باربعه
اهداف مقابله هدفين لاسبانيول واحتفال
لاعبيه بالفوز بلقب الدوري على ملعب
النادي الاخر في الاقليم ليهرب لاعبوا
برشلونه المحتفلون
بصوره تتدخل الشرطه وتمنع جماهير اسبانيول
الغاضبه من الوصول الى اللاعبين في
المباراه التي صنفت قبل لعبها باللقاء
عالي الخطوره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات